maureen dowd author of the book the year
of voting dangerously back in 2010 in
the magazine Irish America they said
this about you Maureen Dowd's scourge of
every president since poppy bush and
arguably the most powerful journalist in
America thanks to her must read column
in The New York Times talking taking the
road not taken' living a quiet life as a
bar keeps life back in Clare I'm talking
about you you your mother your family
your Irishness yeah my that would be my
dad's family my dad's what about the
most loyal team they're journalists in
America well that's what Irish America
would say sure there's another magazine
that thing's Paul Krugman is and another
that thing's Tom Friedman is they were
just giving a boost to what I'm doing I
was born has it been do you beat to be
Irish oh you know it gets more important
as I get older funnily enough when I was
small my dad would make us recite Irish
poetry into one of those old very
initial tape recorders that have the
wheels that went around and my brother's
name is Kevin Barry so he would have to
recite the Irish poem Kevin Barry and I
would have to recite things and you know
at the time a lot of it seemed kind of
corny but then as you get older you know
and now the nation is obsessed with
ancestry and finding out things and as
you get older you realize you know it's
really nice to know everything about
your roots and to have that you know
warm feeling that ancestry can give you
that's something that you wrote about in
your book is a lot of my columns you
have some fresh stuff we'll talk about
that but here is something that you
write about and I want you to explain
this actually a portrait to the audience
right that was such a weird story so
what was the guy's name was at Nelson
spar Nelson shank Nelson shank sorry he
recently died um he he was given a
commission to do an official portrait of
Bill Clinton and for his own reasons
very oddly he had in his studio a
mannequin and a blue dress just randomly
and he put the blue dress on the
mannequin and painted the shadow of that
into the picture and and Bill Clinton
often doesn't have on a wedding ring
which is weird but so then when they
found out I don't think they wanted to
put the painting off and not the
Clintons but it was at a museum and it's
in storage and he was trying to
investigate whether it was in storage
too because he had played this spectral
trick where he had a allusion to the
blue dress and there is a you know a
history of that kind of thing in art but
I think when you get a commission to
paint a president that president
definitely doesn't want you know an
allusion to his White House sex scandal
in there I saw that painting at the
Portrait Gallery and the first thing I
thought I wasn't
I had no idea that there was the blue
dress image on there according to the
artist it's the shoes if the president
United States gets his shoe shined in
right and those are the ugliest looking
at here is in the world I know it was
very strange that he said he did that
and you know what's up for a while and
then they took it down and he suspected
that the Clintons
asked them to take it down but he never
approved it you know but you know I
think they would have a right to it's
such an odd thing to do in an official
portrait in your opinion what are the
chances that he'll be the first spouse
come January the 20th ah I would say at
the rate we're going in the last hour
probably a hundred percent and you know
that's what when you go to Hollywood
that is the story line that all the
Clinton donors are really excited about
because
there was an old Fred MacMurray Polly
Bergen movie called kisses for my
president where she was the first woman
president he was the first lad but
mostly Hollywood hasn't seen anything
like that and when they got Sarah Palin
they got so excited because it opened up
their imaginations to have a beautiful
you know sexy young woman in the role of
Dick Cheney something that had usually
been old gray-haired men so that's where
you get things like deep and you know a
bunch of other things where it had never
occurred to them wow we could have a
babe MS role and in the same way they
love the storyline of Bill Clinton as
first lad or he wants to be called first
laddie Chelsea said because of his Irish
roots but that's more Scottish but um
the funny thing is that Hillary has said
she might let him do the economy and let
Chelsea do the hostessing and she would
Hillary would keep picking out the China
but she really shouldn't do that she
should let bill do the traditional
things first ladies have to do because
it would be a great way to show how
antiquated the job is because Hillary
hated it and chased at it and michelle
has done it beautifully but it is kind
of a white satin jail for a woman like
Hillary or Michelle who have the same
educational credentials as their
husbands so I think if you saw Bill
Clinton doing it you would realize that
maybe we need to modernize the job you
had a column it is in your book from
March 6 2016 this year and it starts out
with here's why the Trump campaign is
wicked fun do you remember what you had
that lasted for about five minutes
well I and in the second part of it was
wait just wicked but the wicked find for
a little bit was just seeing the
political applecart of you know leeches
the political consultants who make
millions of dollars giving candidates
bad advice and who spend Jeb's span
I think $170 on negative ads during the
Republican primary
and trompin seven million hundred sorry
I mean 170 million and Trump was you
know doing his own kind of Instagram
mass and making them up himself and it
was just fun to see that kind of leech
society turned over and to have a more
direct connection between the candidate
and the voters but that didn't last long
because then you know there were all
these births of bigotry and racism and
misogyny which kind of took over the fun
populist part do I count right 21 years
of writing a column oh wow I'd like to
think about that it's been since 95 95
yeah so whatever be 21 years yeah I
think my counting right you only do one
a week now yeah I do one a week and then
I work halftime at our Sunday magazine
for our brilliant no magazine editor
Jake silverstein how do you know that a
column is hit in a nerve oh well you
know we have comments which I never read
but you can see them I didn't see the
number of comments and you know we you
can tell on Twitter and where it's
picked up if it's mentioned you know in
cable news and is there somebody that
calls you on that Sunday morning and
says yeah got on this time I yeah I have
friends who do that they'll read it you
know it comes out Saturday afternoon
basically so I have a bunch of friends
who read it Saturday afternoon and you
can tell if you hear from them or you
don't what they thought what's the best
thing they can say to you oh um just
that they enjoyed it that they thought I
did a good job this is one from February
of 2015
I'll pay for this column you're right
the Rottweilers will be unleashed once
the Clintons had a war room now they
have a slime room once they had the Sly
James car will finally known as serpent
head
now they had the slippery David Brock
accurately known as a snake you know we
have video we're going to show
eventually David brought before and
after right why did you call him a snake
well this is actually something that
really concerns me about the coming
Clinton administration because you know
she does have this idealistic public
service side but then she also over the
decades has developed a kind of a
different site where she often makes
decisions from a darker place of fear
and insecurity and her secretiveness and
defensiveness tends to trip up the light
public service side so to that end she
has sort of surrounded herself with a
lot of you know henchmen who will flying
people who were even saying accurate
things about the Clintons and I think
that speaks to this paranoid side she
has so they are going to come with her
in one way or another either outside the
White House or in the White House and
you know it just worries me because I
wish she could have the confidence to
throw off that kind of person and I
interviewed Bernie Sanders and he was
really concerned about that too because
David Brock had been attacking him on
his age and in these sleazy ways in the
primary and he doesn't understand why
she needs to have this sort of person
around her but in my experience people
tend to get more paranoid in the White
House at the very moment that the whole
country affirms them and they should
feel confident and you know they often
they're gremlins come out then that's
not only with presidents you know with
any any chief executives and alphas
oftentimes that's when their
insecurities come out when they get to
the top which seems counterintuitive but
it's pretty common
this is video book from 1993 and from
2015
of david brock and you can see him when
he worked for the american spectator and
the clinton project funded by richard
Mellon Scaife
right and you can see him now as he
raises money for Hillary Clinton and
runs the other side he switched complete
size just take a look at this
Larry Patterson is quoted as saying that
it was common knowledge at the
governor's residence that mrs. Clinton
and Vince Foster were intimately
involved when Governor Clinton would
leave town
very shortly thereafter Vince foster
would regularly show up at the mansion
and stay to all hours of the night with
mrs. Clinton they often were driven out
to a a retreat that the rose law firm
kept a cabin outside of Little Rock
where they spent extensive time together
much to my own surprise and certainly to
my professional detriment as a
right-wing hitman I wrote about a woman
with a steadfast commitment to public
service a lifelong passion for children
and families and a deep well of personal
integrity how does this happen
I don't know well it was his work on you
know the state troopers in Arkansas that
ended up leading to impeachment right
with Paula Jones and everything but he
the irony to me is he was the main kind
of attack dog smearing and need a hill
it's a little [ __ ] a little bit
naughty and a little [ __ ] and then he
had his conversion on the road to
Damascus and and Bill Clinton called him
because he liked his book blinded by the
write and they kind of brought him in in
the same way Bill Clinton spoke at
Steve's funeral so the Clintons you know
kind of helped turn him around and he
now runs one of the you know PACs that
or the media kind of conglomerate that
defends her and goes after people who
even write accurate things about her and
so the irony is he was smearing Anita
Hill and then now he's part of the
Clinton team and the Clinton team Sidney
Blumenthal and Charlie Rangel and a
little bit Hillary were kind of smearing
Monica is a little nutty
little [ __ ] so that's a very
interesting kind of arc right there but
while we're on it
you gotta explain this this is a picture
of you you you can toss where this came
from
yeah because we Sydney Blumenthal no we
just happen to be standing in line
I just wasn't with anyone and he was in
line in front of me so they took us
together and it's funny because bill had
a has an allergy you know he has a lot
of allergies and he has an allergy to
trees that they always photoshopped at
the Christmas tree and afterwards and
Bill and I both have on very lovely ties
yeah well knows that um gosh well that
was probably at the beginning of the
Clinton administration I'm in Miami Hall
look but the thing is that um I feel
sorry for presidents for the media
Christmas party because they have to
stand there and pose with all of the
reporters that they probably are
seething about and I don't think it's a
very pleasant evening for them you know
it's a constant sub-theme in the last
two years about Sidney Blumenthal how
does he fit in this well Donald Trump
keeps trying to bring him up in the
debate and you know at rallies and no
one knows who he is and unless I mean
people in Washington do but none of
these people at Trump rallies do and
it's just so funny to see Trump trying
to make that stick but you know it's a
rare case where Trump is right that
Sidney Blumenthal was one of the ones
who you know was smearing people and
what is the issue that he came up in
most recently the he would do that I
know exactly what you're talking yeah
we're on out of the birther thing where
Hillary um you know he was trying to say
that Hillary actually started the
birther thing and then it turns out that
Sidney Blumenthal did go to a McClatchy
reporter and suggest that McClatchy sin
a reporter to Kenya to check out that
the NFC if Obama was really born in
Kenya so there you know as would always
with Trump there can be a kernel of
truth and what he is saying that doesn't
excuse his absurd and offensive birther
you know campaign but Sydney but there
were Hillary people calling reporters
and trying to suggest the same thing
here's some more video this time and you
write about Dick Morris who worked for
Bill Clinton and now works for the other
side of the bestseller and the New York
Times bestseller list from the right
side of things but here he is and it
kind of goes back to what you said in
the first place about watching this town
and what it's all about here but here's
1998 and 2016 this is the same man the
Democrats do not want the abortion
debate to be resolved they do not want
gun control to be passed they do not
want necessarily our environmental
problems to be solved because they're
too good for getting votes and that
essentially what he decided to do was to
take each of the problems we faced as a
society and in a very workmanlike way in
an almost non partisan way bring them to
solution and solve them and I think he
succeeded overwhelmingly now corruption
and money-making is the be-all and
end-all of this couples life they have
gone from a romance in the 1970s and 80s
to a partnership in the 90s to a RICO a
racketeering organization today we're
Bill's job is to pass the bag and
Hilary's job is to offer access and
favors to those who put money inside it
Wow you know um toe-sucking
by a call girl in the Jefferson hotel
seems so quaint anymore at the time
except I was anywhere yeah crazy sex
scandal when Dick Morris was caught
doing that you know now we've got all
kinds of vulgarity and crew to tease and
raise how much of what we just seen
as anything to do with the attitude the
American people have toward this town
this business politics election well I
think I think the cases you shown are
extreme cases but that's what's
disturbing about the Clintons because
they will hire anyone who can help them
win and you know I was at that
convention where that story broke about
the toe sucking and he had to resign and
I think Hillary had helped bring him
back in and you know yeah he was very um
I think that was part of their kind of
DLC conservative streak that they
brought to democratic politics the
toe-sucking story is the Jefferson hotel
in Washington was he with a call girl
and talking on the phone I think to
Clinton and congressmen and stuff where
are you on the cynic skeptic scale at
this time in your life here I think God
you know oftentimes people think
journalists are cynics but I think
actually where I deal with you know I I
am I am definitely not cynical maybe you
know you get a little jaded if you see
enough things that disillusion you but
basically I think the reason people want
to be journalists it's because they're
idealist this is from May 30th of 2015 I
recently interviewed several dozen the
Hollywood players mostly on background
because of fears about the famed Clinton
vindictive streak how does that work to
start why I've got more to read but how
does that work when you're riding out of
a how do they go on background or on
off-the-record
yeah I think you know Hillary and Trump
are known you know for vindictive
streaks so it's hard to it's hard to get
people to go on the record when when
you're talking about either of them
tonight they say to you this is off the
record or you say to them how do you
want me to quote this you know
well both and in that case I remember
one woman who was a very involved in all
the races of the Clintons in Hollywood
and you know a donor said the problem
with the Clintons but she didn't want to
say this on the record because they all
knew probably there would be another
Clinton administration but she said the
problem with the Clintons is you kind of
get right in the middle of a campaign or
a White House with them and something
blows up you know that that is their
modus operandi so with Hillary the email
thing was breaking and they were unsure
you know but they're kind of handcuffed
to this rollercoaster where with the
Clintons there's always some snakes it's
popping out of a can you didn't know
about that maybe a small thing that
they've hidden or maybe a large thing
that they've hidden but then it kind of
comes tumbling out and in in opportune
moment the Hollywood thing go back to
that column they aren't over the moon
about Barack Obama you wrote in 2015
anymore right even feel burned he was
like a razzle dazzle trailer that turned
out to be a disappointing movie with
mediocre box office right well I think
the in the tulip craze of 2008 Barack
Obama and Michelle you know sold Obama
as I remember Michelle saying this isn't
about politics this is about our souls
you know was more than politics it was
something cleaner and finer and pressure
and and people thought they were turning
and in Hollywood that was ground zero of
people who were betraying the Clinton
machine when I did the interview with
David Geffen and I think that people
like Geffen and other people in
Hollywood who you know change sides and
went with Obama against the Clinton
machine did not think eight years later
Obama would put out the red carpet for
the Clinton machine because now all
these people I think Geffen is given the
minimum but you know now they're going
to be pariahs
anyone who left the Clintons will
or for Obama why is President Obama
working so hard for mrs. Clinton well
the first african-american president
does not want his legacy erased by the
most overtly racist candidate in modern
time certainly and Michelle to who and
she's an amazing campaigner and I think
that that's about his legacy more than
it is about the Clintons although
Hillary is his hand-picked choice he
pushed Biden aside for her you wrote in
February 2016 this year Lyndon Johnson
said that the two things that make
politicians more stupid than anything
else are sex and envy with Hillary there
are three things sex money and the need
for secrecy yeah it's so weird that this
campaign is is like the revenge of the
90s and both candidates are kind of
greed as good candidates in a weird way
and all these figures from the 90s like
Newt Gingrich and Rudy Giuliani are back
and I know you know I recently reread
all the biographies of Hillary and my
own I start out covering her in 92 very
supportive Lee I was surprised when I
went back and read it when when she was
running as bills life and healthcare I
was very supportive even as a news
reporter but um somewhere along the way
maybe when she got to Arkansas and the
marriage was rocky and she thought she
might have to support the family maybe
it's one of these things like John
Sununu where you think I'm doing public
service but I think I should get what I
would have gotten if I gone into the
private sector but somewhere along the
way she did get this fixation on money
which it's weird because they they made
so many you know hundreds of millions
even if they spend a bunch every day
they could never spend it right so why
on earth would end
if you're if she's going to be president
and he's going to be the first first lad
they'll get you know 20 million each to
do memoirs once they're in there so why
would you go to goldman sachs and make
those $675,000 speeches i mean it's you
know they're tin cup should be in the
Smithsonian you know in that same speech
I was on the same column you wrote about
the Nelson shanks and the portrait you
also bring up the fact that Michael
Schmitt of the times was the one that
started the whole email story right
reason I bring that up and ask you about
it is if you listen to the right-wing
talk-show hosts they are constantly
excoriating the new york times of being
in Hillary's camp why I don't know you
know Michael Schmidt is a brilliant
reporter in the Washington bureau he's
like a throwback you know to 30s
reporters where he is a real
investigative reporter and he broke the
lot of the steroid stories and baseball
and then he came to Washington and he
broke this story and you know the
Clinton people can say although all they
want that it's a tempest in a teapot but
what she did was really really reckless
in in so many ways and and that's what
worries me about her the paranoia that
caused her to make that kind of reckless
decision it's it's sort of unfathomable
and and one thing I don't like about the
Clintons is when they get in trouble and
Donald Trump does this too when they get
in trouble they try and blame someone
else so you know when Bill got in
trouble with Monica the White House
aides will call around and say well
Thomas Jefferson has a mistress dead
presidents they're dragging in right and
JFK had a mistress and then you're like
okay fine just why don't you just
confess what you did but Bill Clinton
will never you know would never admit it
he would like drag everyone into say he
was telling the truth and his wife would
try and savage the girlfriends and then
years later he would
to admit it so it's just a very
unhealthy and then on the email Hillary
said we'll call them how did you know
but the state of the Internet had
changed profoundly and new rules had
been put in place so don't drag poor
Colin Powell into it it's just not
comparable so which one of these
candidates these prime candidates mr.
Trump mrs. Clinton would be the best for
columnist lowering down oh um well
obviously you know you're right the
journalists have a citizen side and
journalists side an office in here in
conflict
Carl hulls our chief Washington
correspondent often has the same a bad
for the country good for Carl and that
is a kind of a weird thing to explain to
people outside the business but
obviously Donald Trump would be better
for journalism because it would be utter
freakin chaos around the world but then
as a citizen of course you have a
contrary opinion one of the things I
noticed when you write you drop in well
you rap in many references to
Shakespeare would you've studied
Shakespeare Catholic University but
night but you drop in French all the
time ah and if someone who doesn't speak
French yeah I don't speak it either I
want to show you I'm going to put this
well this isn't just French these are
words these are maureen dowd words that
you use in your columns up there do you
realize how many of us have no idea what
you're talking about when you drop these
in I know that doesn't bother me at all
because I think words are so much fun
and I don't do it to be pretentious I do
it because I I want people to have
different words and to learn words and
you know I took Latin all through school
and Latin and played Scrabble all
through school and I think they really
those two things helped me a lot with my
vocabulary and I just think it's really
fun
you drop in fun words and in fact I just
had a column go up about what sort of a
fun column about what Milania was up to
at the debate and I have a French
phrases can't see you have something to
look forward to well now I want to show
you that these are just definitions you
find in the dictionary you may have met
them different ways course sisyphus is a
long story do you look these up
beforehand and drop the men or do you
know them and drop them in so sometimes
I know them and sometimes I feel like
I'm relying on the same words you know
they have computer programs that can
imitate the columnist like that they put
in all our columns and then it can fit
out a column that look reads like ours
and Tom Friedman's and everything and so
I don't want to keep falling back on the
same words and when I feel myself doing
that I just go do this this Orascom and
try and get different words because that
you know it's more fun for me I don't
want to keep using the same 80
adjectives all the time here's just
three more words and phrases my favorite
is the bottom one yeah
seasickness and that's what Jacques
Chirac had when George Bush Senior took
him out on his motorboat the fidelity he
had to plead mal de mer yeah and then
there's the rest I won't try to
pronounce mirabile addictive yeah that's
from Latin that's from my days studying
Latin in Catholic schools clearly
Shakespeare has played a big role in
your life my why what we had an op-ed
piece by a Shakespeare scholar in The
Times this week about blood yeah Richard
the third and and talking about power
because and I understand this is really
hard for New York Times readers because
they get very upset with me because they
want me to be a reliable you know
liberal but I don't write a column that
comes from the left or the right and I
think I'm the only one who does a
political column that doesn't have an ID
logical slant so it's hard for people to
understand and even my own family gets
very um upset with me when a Republican
president is in you know because I'm
critiquing the Republican president and
then a lot of times readers get upset
with me when the Democratic president is
and because I'm critiquing that
president but I see it more like
Shakespeare where I'm trying to examine
the effect that great power has on
people who get it so does the power wort
them in some way that we need to know
about or did they rise to the occasion
like Harry Truman did and kind of become
more than you thought they could be he
was a hack in a machine politician and
he was Harry Truman you know so it's
very interesting to me how crises like
9/11 for instance if it weren't for 9/11
George Bush might have been a bipartisan
popular president but that completely
changed him and brought out all his
insecurities and made him more malleable
- Dick Cheney and Don Rumsfeld and so we
never know which enormous historical
event is going to coincide with which
new presidents gremlins and so I quote
Harry Truman and the introduction saying
you never know how a man is going to
take the responsibility of being
president and you don't so in a way you
can follow candidates for two years and
not know what they're really like
because double used to say he'd have a
humble foreign policy and then it turned
out to be Dick Cheney trying to turn
this into a hyper power you know so it
has to be more than what they say we
have to kind of examine once they get in
how that power is changing them and how
they are they are rising or falling well
why did you get interested in
Shakespeare and win um
yeah in college I was in English you
know literature major and I was just
drawn to Shakespeare and the same for
the same reason I'm now drawn to Game of
Thrones I mean I love is someone a
reader Romans that I should have been
like a French court reporter in the 18th
century I love watching the Royal Court
and how it deals with power you know I
mean in Shakespeare people are you're
dealing with regis side
on the side and patricide and you know
it gets very bloody but it deals with
primary emotions like jealousy and envy
and desire and I'm just very interested
in primary emotions as as a writer I
know said you know I'm not interested in
these little stories about how someone
goes to CBS and buys a bottle of aspirin
is having a bad day I mean I like like
those fellow Macbeth kind of emotions
and you see that in this campaign with
Donald Trump I mean you're seeing such a
range of deep crazy emotions he would
fit right into Shakespeare ok this sent
me to YouTube Kellyanne Conway
comes dirty campaign manager attempted
to communicate with her fragile Blanche
DuBois candidate last week through an
appearance on the view here's an excerpt
of the movie featuring Blanche DuBois
might explain I want you to explain my
being late yes
Vivian Lee now fine did you figure that
we all know what this Blanche DuBois
character was I mean it's obviously that
Tennessee Williams pretty hard a traitor
doesn't know and they do what you did
think of the treat in store for them
because that's one of the best movies of
all time so what go back to that quote
that you said about Kellyanne Conway and
her candidate right because the whole
dynamic of this campaign which is so
bizarre
is this cascading series of advisers
tiptoeing around Donald Trump who is a
clinical narcissist having a
narcissistic explosion right on the
trail and trying to get him to do the
obvious like prepare for a debate you
know we wouldn't do it he was sitting
around with Roger Ailes eating bacon
cheeseburgers and trying to come up with
zingers and Roger Ailes was telling more
stories and complaining about Rupert
Murdoch so that is not debate prep so
it's just you know if you can laugh at
this campaign it's it's so hilarious to
see all of these aides on eggshells
trying to get you know it's like the
taming of the shrew to throw in another
play by Shakespeare so so they're trying
to get Donald Trump to do the basic
minimum he needs to do in order to have
a campaign and yet they can you know
they can't he's like one of these mad
German kings locked in his castle in
Trump Tower like look blood big and you
know getting more isolated and not
talking to any bananas up there today
like sending out 10 tweets thrashing
Paul Ryan who has said he won't campaign
with him and all the Republicans and
they're ungrateful and they're just all
and I mean that is a scene straight out
of Shakespeare so words what's your
reaction to this tweet from Donald Trump
whacky at New York Times Dowd who hardly
knows me makes up things that I never
said for her boring interviews and
column a neurotic dope I was really
deeply disturbed by this because I have
you know covering and most off and on
since 1999 and I really thought that I
would get a more customized nickname
you know like Elizabeth Warren has
Pocahontas and Chuck Todd has sleepy
eyes and he just gave me the same one he
gives all the women journalists wacky
and crazy and neurotic I just did not
make me feel special the other night was
crazy Maureen Dowd like he columnist for
the failing at New York Times pretend
she knows me wrong and yet and you I
will do how much time have you spent
around okay so I went out for a day to
Miami with him in 99 when he made one of
his first I think his first presidential
for a and he was dating Melania been and
we only done to Miami and he made a
speech to Cuban Americans on the gilded
plane with the fake French impressionist
art and you know I wasn't taking it
seriously then he was a celebrity who
just wanted to test the waters he had a
brand anything that could you know bring
attention to the brand and then I would
interview him over the years he liked to
do lightning rounds because that's how
he prefers he doesn't want to sit down
and have discussions about the issues
because as you know he doesn't really
know about the issues basically he
orders up every day he gets his press
secretary to given the top 30 pieces
about himself and then he reads those so
it's this constant incestuous
amplification of his own persona and
publicity so you know all right I've got
some video that we found it's 12 years
old I know you love television only with
you Brian yes sure I know you love
television so here's some television you
may not have ever seen okay okay this
goes back it's about a minute and a half
this first one goes back to September
the 13th 2004 and you'll see some people
in here you know including your deceased
brother Michael oh is this the c-span
bull party oh wow here we go get Peggy
down on TV this is the
[Applause]
they're all the brains come from idea is
my sister she really I really wanted me
to answer no I am Jessica you were the
first page and I am well is wonderful
before now mr. Putnam kill me when my
brother was at page four press that was
really nice a memorial right now I was I
worked in the Senate and we deliver mail
to all the officers and I were told you
were instructed by people senior to you
if you go in for Senator John Kennedy's
office let me happen to be there do not
talk do not even look at don't say it's
a nice day openness keep your head down
the bursar I really it because you're
poor lot they look in your direction but
otherwise just said anything night Reyes
assemble the look the servant it's
obvious
well any other hand vice president
Richard Nixon was one of the nicest
people I ever met now judy Woodruff was
in there your back was to the camera and
that's your brother who died in 2007 and
mom was in there we had in 2005 right
you write a lot about them it's in this
book and all what about your brother
Michael about your mom yeah I was super
close and then my dad was 61 when I was
born so Michael was 17 years older than
I was so he kind of helped raise me and
um yeah he was he was a Google before
there was Google he had an absolutely
encyclopedic memory he was the most
voracious reader I've ever known and
just a brilliant guy and he was one of
the ones who would get mad at me when I
was covering W kind of harshly about the
Iraq war and and when I don't home for
Thanksgiving he'd say you know if there
was a hurricane you'd blame it on W and
then there was Katrina and I did so that
was a little bit of a tense time you
know in our family I wrote about it more
lightly in the column but you know it's
hard it's hard when what you do
conflicts with how well you want to get
along with your family how about mom how
old was she when she is my absolute Idol
she was 97 if you could see still
gorgeous and she loved him Russert he
would call her every mother's day and
she was wonderful she was like
completely literate she would she would
tell me she'd go to a Oscar Wilde
reading of Oscar Wilde's work and she
was very interested because Jackie
Kennedy was there and you know she had a
lot of stories about politics too but
basically she was just the epitome of
what you want a mother to be but also an
American you know she just was very fair
and very loving person
and very smart and very patriotic she
always wore she would get very angry at
me if I didn't wear a red white and blue
on July 4 and your five kids in the
including you and the family right
here's some more from this we've got
some more from this party let's go nice
linen flower garden I'm miked up on
c-span and if they're still listening
this is my doctor to help you through
well yes diagnose me is being tutored on
TV Letterman that was terrifying
wonderful go oh my gosh I thought I was
going to faint when I said to David
Letterman goes are you okay like you saw
my face because are you okay that's what
you're saying I'm the audience was
clapping women and I can yeah and I said
no I'm not okay get her okay sit down
many tried to calm me down by telling me
about going fly fishing with brothah
like off air you know he was trying to
calm me down saying he bought a place in
Montana up Hasbro so I had one there and
so then he was saying you know I went
fishing with Tom for it was the small
talk that was supposed to calm me down
now I can't get off TV I'm in determined
general they follow me every
Alexandra's sailing that monster just
get up kitty monster the funny thing was
because I'm so shy and introverted and
because I only go on TV is you know if a
publisher as a gun to my head my family
just was stunned that I was willing to
be miked up you know for a book party
that was so out of character and out of
my nature what it was but it is c-span
and I love c-span so I wouldn't do it
for anyone you ever watch this now I
never have the nerve to read anything or
watch anything about myself but you miss
there was a hilarious scene where Ben
Bradley was stuffing his face with her
d'oeuvres at the table we're not done I
mean it was even though it was
completely out of character I did kind
of love it because I look at all those
people who are great kind of
larger-than-life people in my life but
also in Washington history like Ben
Bradley and Tim Russert and it's really
fun to have them on tape the names of it
coming up here you're going to see lanny
davis pat out of him whose cartoon
elephant dude the cartoon Forbush world
and he's a brilliant political
cartoonist to work with me at the star
who's australian and he he compares my
work to political cartoons and he says
that what we do for a living is stirring
up the Beast I mean I see Chris Matthews
bill Plante Joe Wilson Nigeria Valerie
Plame his wife Peter biner
used to be with a new republic at the
time I think Kyle Thomas Judy Woodruff
al hunt her husband Bill pres Sally
Quinn Gail Collins who was at the time
of this would she have been your boss at
The Times go column yeah maybe you know
page yeah well my theory of parties
which is why no one will come to a party
at my house anymore is just to invite
everyone you know everyone from my
electrician to my boss to
ooh Vice President Biden and then see
who shows up this is 12 years ago other
names you're going to see Rahm Emanuel
is now the mayor of Chicago Chris
Buckley Ben Bradlee Andrea Mitchell and
Alan Greenspan and there's a guy with a
t-shirt on you're muted you remember who
that was probably my electrician I know
that was funny because Alan Greenspan at
this inaugural party I had when Barack
Obama got elected in 2008 came up to me
very disapprovingly and he goes is this
a toga party it was crap he had never
been to a party like that I have to say
you've got to watch at the end Alan
Greenspan and Ben Bradlee oh great let's
roll okay no but I'm meeting a lot of
new people here you are oh my gosh and
it was asking for you everybody spin the
president's coming any minute I can't
get off TV which is coming itself
regarding paying of course I do you can
just how are you well it might be Kenny
but I read about it all right column
take us off baby
see fanfare party talentless here on
behalf of all the people from the times
I just want to say how happy we are that
it's been so wonderful because it's
everything that Maureen deserves this
fan is leaving now and now we can really
get down to the real party
and that's when he said yeah the guy in
Bern you just is a friend of my brothers
who lived on suburban Maryland who just
came along but I think if you only have
like one kind of person at your party
there's no energy you've got to kind of
mix it up why why would you I mean you
worried all about people far away from
her saying something like this and
saying they're just out of touch that
whole crowds out of touch with the right
America um well I know I didn't just
think hanging out and having hors
d'oeuvres means you're out of touch you
know it's funny because a lot of my
fellow colonists have been going on
these road trips they drive across
country or they put out open letters
seeking to meet a trump voter and so I'm
always picking up the paper and seeing
them driving through Kentucky and trying
to find a Trump voter and somebody else
didn't open letter please Trump voter
come and let me reason with you I would
like to meet one of these exotic
creatures like a Margaret Mead and to
watch across expedition and all I have
to do is go home you know I I watched
the debate with my sister and she told
me why Trump persuaded heard that she
might vote for him again and she she and
my brother up essays in the book so I I
do not think of myself as an elitist you
know I feel like I am deep and you know
it and I get both the blue and the red
state opinions pretty freely your
brother Kevin and your sister Peggy are
in the book you they've written their
own essays are they still going to vote
for Donald Trump well at this moment
perhaps not by the time they see Harris
they still seem to be voting for Donald
Trump because my sister keeps jumping on
and off when he says something offensive
and
you know she said she wasn't going to
vote for him after the wild crazy week
of him trashing Alicia Machado and in
these 3 a.m. tweets where he kept
insisting she had gained all this weight
and my sister said she hates fat shaming
and she was completely disgusted but
then we watched the debate and she was
kind of back on board because and as my
brother said Trump was not his first
second or even third choice but they
feel very strongly they don't want
Hillary Clinton to be president and they
want the Supreme Court that a Republican
president would appoint so that's their
point of view I know Hillary keeps
saying to people I'm the only thing
standing between you and the abyss or
you and the apocalypse and a lot of
people do believe that but then my
family kind of sees her as Eve this so I
got one more piece of tape at paint
Johnson's it's past and he might have
and everybody in this tape this is what
was amazing when we look look back at it
had died something maybe this was 2000
not not everybody in all the tape we've
seen but in this particular 40 second
tape these folks were alive very much so
back in 2004 let's just watch this and
these folks are gone now I invited you
that day in the elevator but now with
you anyway are ya the prospects Josh hi
marina how
hi I'll be right back I went answer this
dynamic for my brother
sitting right next to it on bars I'm
taking a picture of Sam and Jennifer now
in the greatest editor in the history of
newspaper that's a lot of seats a living
it's very rare to even have Democrats
and Republicans of parties anymore you
know in the old advise and consent days
they would meet at parties and there'd
be these famous Washington hostesses and
that's where they get a lot of their
business done but that isn't the way it
works anymore we saw tony blankley who
worked for ryan rich reign Bradley you
know ten bucks I said this is the
greatest debtor in the history of the
world the people in the journalism
business when they hear that from
somebody else believe it well Ben
Bradley was very special and Phil gayly
who wrote for us had a great analogy
about him that he said other newspapers
were the kind of Nova and the suburban
garage but Ben Bradley was the little
red roadster taking the curves a little
too fast and he was just so dashing you
know dashing and kind of a one of a kind
throw bags at the great days of
journalism all of those folks are you
know it's sad that they're gone but the
one that's really was the bad one and
there besides Tim Russert died at age 58
was David Rosen mom oh the New York
Times and we didn't see much of him but
tell that story now in the saddest story
ever David Riza mom was such a fantastic
guy and he was our longtime
congressional reporter and just a very
happy guy and a hard worker and a really
great reporter and he retired and very
soon after his retirement within I think
a month or two he was just he always
would take a walk after dinner on Friday
night he lived in a very safe
neighborhood in the District of Columbia
yes but in
you know very Toni kind of safe
neighborhood and these two guys came up
behind him I guess they wanted to rob
him and hit him with a lead pipe and
they took him to the emergency room and
the people in the emergency room thought
he was drunk or something they just
didn't realize and Colby King did a
wonderful series of columns in the
Washington Post and I think got some
legislation or some procedures change
because of it and David died and it was
heartbreaking so this book your third
you ever want to write I mean the second
one you actually wrote the book about
man I actually wrote no I mean you know
I mean these are a lot of these are
called mostly columns and all did you
ever have it they have I did a very long
essay that I rerecorded on my thirty
years with the Bush family where I have
um the letters that George Bush Senior
wrote me and it's a crazy kind of almost
like a screwball class comedy like the
Irish working-class girl reporter and
the waspy president who was driven to
school and Greenwich and a limousine and
how hard it was for us to accept each
other and how in the end we did and even
developed you know a fondness for each
other still in contact yeah I went down
and had lunch with them a couple years
ago and there's a picture of that in the
book and here's a funny thing so this
was before Donald Trump was running and
the fondest wish of Bush Senior was that
Jeb would become president and maybe
make the legacy a little better than W
left it and so I asked him Donald Trump
was deeply involved in the birther stuff
at that time and so Bush senior said he
loved Bill Clinton you know Barbara
calls him the brother from another
mother and he said he loved Barack Obama
who keeps in good touch with him
and then I said what do you think of
Donald Trump and George for senior just
had an epithet for him you know he was
so disgusted with him so I can't even
imagine how painful it was for him to
see him destroy Jeb in what Trump very
crassly likes to call a one-day kill
because of the low energy money moniker
so Bush Senior apparently would throw
his shoe with the TV says whenever Trump
came on if folks want to know more about
this story ins a long one in your book
they must get your book and the name of
the book is the year of voting
dangerously the derangement of American
politics Pulitzer prize-winning
columnist Maureen Dowd we are out of
time and I thank you thank you fine